Global News is obscuring the images as
they are simply too disturbing for
broadcast a man in a military-style
uniform kneels on another pinning the
victim down as he saws at his neck with
a knife
there is something that no one in the
world can ignore how easily these beasts
kill Ukraine's security service has
opened yet another war crimes
investigation because of the videos it's
not known who made or posted them to
social media the Kremlin spokesperson
described them as awful and called for
their authentication
in the world of fakes that we inhabit
says Dimitri paskov we need to check the
veracity of this footage
in the beheading video another
individual is seen grabbing a flak
jacket and showing the camera the
Ukrainian Trident patch in a separate
video there is what appears to be a
destroyed armor personnel carrier and
two bodies visible without heads the
videos are likely a few months old as
the ground is dry and there's Greenery
in the frame the grizzly recording
surfaced just days after Russia took up
the presidency position at the un's
security Council each member state gets
a month-long rotation the Ukrainian
foreign minister tweeted saying it's
absurd that Russia which is worse than
Isis is presiding over the UNSC
on the front lines neither side appears
to be gaining or losing much ground in
bakmut it's been the site of one of the
bloodiest and longest battles since
Russia launched its full invasion of
Ukraine 14 months ago Vladimir zielinski
says Terror must be defeated in Ukraine
and as he highlighted the horrors in the
video he again called for the world to
support his soldiers
Crystal gemancing Global News London